The Joe Rogan Experience now when The
Chimps are on patrol that's a uniquely
intense and aggressive moment and it's
so wild to watch to see them these
hulking chimpanzees move through the
forest in coordination when you're there
with that and you're very close to these
violent encounters with the other chimps
is there any concern there that you
could get caught up in this sort of
violent frenzy and maybe be in danger of
being attacked or
you know
the the the there isn't actually that
that I mean the what let me let me
rephrase that I would say on a personal
level of course right you know you come
you hear about these things
happening you know it's a possibility
we'll be there when it happens when it's
filmed so we ask exactly the same
question so this is you know I've been
through the exact same process as you
are now and have this conversation with
the scientists like are we going to be
safe right you know is it safe for us to
where should we be or where should we
not be if this happens when we're there
so
totally weird exactly the same questions
and we just didn't know and we were
reassured by the scientists you know
you'll you'll be amazed like wow you see
those things they will happen but they
will ignore you and their only warning
was that
definitely don't get too close you know
the because the level of excitement
um Around The Chimps during these
encounters you know if there's ever a
time when they could accidentally come
very close to you or suddenly see you
and get a bit of a fright you know that
they wouldn't want they wouldn't want to
take that sort of a risk with us so they
did they did we were warned you know
keep a respectful distance from that
but
amazingly and there's a little um
a little behind the scenes clip that
we've sort of released on on YouTube now
and and you can see that
during
during the the biggest encounter that we
filmed
um
the the camera people were sort of like
in it and I'm around it and sort of at
one stage sort of like accidentally
between the two groups standing off and
you know that the certain way I mean The
Chimps move so fast and they organize
reorganize separate or whatever so you
can try and be in the perfect position
but then that perfect position could
quickly become where you don't want to
be because of where the chimps have gone
so through no fault of their own
um you know there are times when they're
sort of they're in there sort of
it's a bit like being a war reporter or
something
um but
weirdly you know they're so focused on
what it is they're doing and have no
interest in sort of involving or
redirecting their aggression to to the
humans at all
I think
you know because of
you know there are some quite high
profile and sort of like pretty tragic
sort of human chimp
interactions
no no I mean sort of like things that
have happened at zoos or yes or whatever
and I think that
it I think it does give a sort of an an
unusual impression of what gyms are like
in in the wild they they have all that
sort of capability and more so you know
the ingogo chimps there's so many of
them and and they are engaged in these
sort of violent competitions with other
groups that's a very real thing and and
and you know and it can get serious
but their relationship with people is
just completely
different
to
a relationship chimps might have with
people in captivity or if they've been
kept as pets or something
um
yeah it's just it's it's not I I totally
get it in those exactly the sort of
things I wanted to know before I stepped
in and go go well I mean you know for
sure you you need to know
um
but amazingly when you've been there
around it
and even once you've just been on a
single Patrol with them actually and
they're exhilarating when you go on
patrol within Google gyms it's it's
amazing
they are taking you on a journey to the
edge of that border and they they're
fully committed and they're coordinated
and and we don't seem to care that
you're following and they're allowing
you to sort of be there that's amazing
yeah
it's a it's an incredible experience
actually it's real adrenaline yeah there
they are look at that this was my
favorite part just watching them moving
coordination and just wondering like
what how do they know like what are they
doing almost seems like they're
gesturing in some ways like that chimp
with the one hand okay so this is a
behind the scenes but yeah exactly you
know gestures quite often that
oh it hands all over each other yeah
that that's undeniable this sort of
reassuring yeah gestures they they know
they're they're in this like tense
situation they're nervous
I think that you can read into that that
they're sort of telling each other that
like I'm with you I'm with you I'm here
that physical contact is just
you know it's just reassuring each other
that we're in this together
um it's you and me
and when violence does break out what is
that experience like
I mean when you're seeing Chimp on chimp
violence from several feet away I mean
that has to be wild
I didn't let's say we I mean I don't
really want to give away any spoilers
for the series because some of some of
these things are sort of like major plot
points in this series I I know what
you're saying and I appreciate your
artistics it doesn't matter but it's so
good it's so good that even if you say
what happens and people get to see it
it's so yeah I mean and I would say that
like like I said I often personally well
I wasn't there for many of the things
that happened
uh but it was some and I and I have been
there previously in GoGo where certain
things have happened
um
it's hard I I think that is
Chimp on chimp violence is is a lot
harder
um
to watch
than the chimple monkey violence for me
personally
and whether I'm there myself or whether
I'm seeing it recorded later on I think
there's a this kind of a sadness to that
personally
um quite often it's because in truth the
it gets more serious if the chimps
outnumber them significantly so when
when chimps are kind of equal sized
groups when they come into contact
they're usually less violent situations
because it's too much danger it's
there's no there's too much danger too
much at stake it's kind of a bit bravado
so they run at each other a few times
but if there's enough chimps on either
side
you can pretty much know that in this
immediate situation no one's going to
get badly hurt
uh they get badly hit when they're
outnumbered and obviously that on a
human level
just no one likes seeing that sort of
thing yeah you know there's there's just
a
yeah that that it's just horrible it and
and it you know
unfortunately we've all sort of seen
that personally or clips of that in
humans and it's the most uncomfortable
horrible stuff and it really makes you
horrible
um
so
yeah all of that stuff is very hard to
watch it wasn't sorry well then I'll
just say even you know interestingly
like I say we the scientists are in GoGo
we know them really well now and we've
worked with them for a long time so you
know we share things and they share
stories that on a more personal level
with us
um but they are obviously better than we
or a view would be detaching themselves
you know this is just what happens
they're there to observe and try and
understand it's not an emotional thing
but even even they who have been there
for many years and I think particularly
because they've been there for many
years sometimes you see an act of
violence on on a chimp that you've known
and been following around for ages that
he may not care about you but you really
care about them and and it's sad yeah
it's very sad
during the filming or at least on the
show there's one instance of the
chimpanzees killing uh another chimp was
there more of that
I'm not I'm not okay you think it's a
spoiler alert but I'm telling you it's
just fine it's so cool so fascinating
and so good yeah I don't okay good no no
that's fine
I know it's you for me
doesn't really matter it doesn't I don't
know it's so good it doesn't matter okay
yes okay so that happens
uh was it only one time while you were
there
wow yes no the well there's another
thing in the series we're not going to
talk about okay like because that really
is
a spoiler but
um
yes couple of occasions
whilst we were there
and that is how I mean does it is it
conflicted do you almost have this like
feeling that you want to intervene and
protect the chimp or
I think yeah everybody
who's been around those feelings you
wish it wouldn't happen right you you
don't want this to conclude in the way
that you think it might
um but again I think I I totally
understand what why you're asking but I
think once once you've been around them
enough and you and you have to have this
commitment to and it's part it's part of
the same point that you're asking
earlier about that impact on their lives
you want zero impact on their lives or
or minimal right
you don't want any negative impact you
actually can't make up too much of a
positive impact either
you know also it just wouldn't be
practical it's not it's not safe you
know you know what could you do shout
and make a noise and try and disturb
them just enough for a moment the the
chimp could get away and
you know
possibly but I think that it wouldn't be
you know it wouldn't be ethical right to
do it these are
it is natural behavior I mean that's my
take on it from what I've seen uh
the these this is part of their natural
behavior they are
competitive and they're Territorial and
those you know those behaviors have
served to them well in in the past so
you can't as much as it's not from a
human Observer point of view
that same thing taking that same
situation out is something you observed
in the street all those natural sort of
tendency desires to intervene and stop
something you know they're there for
good reason
um but you know this is the the entire
sort of the entire scientific project
our commitment as filmmakers to observe
but not interfere I mean that's that's
all part of the same thing you couldn't
if you stepped out of that role
in any circumstance you've kind of
you've crossed a line in a really odd
way
um but so so and in a way that sort of
helps with the what you're feeling when
you see or observe those things because
well you know there's absolutely nothing
you can do about this right I mean of
course ethically you really can't
intervene
but it's still sort of
I mean what a an amazing experience for
you as a human being to have gone
through this it's just such a rare rare
insight into the these animals and these
incredibly unique creatures and their
behavior it's just you must feel so
fortunate just to experience just as a
human being just as a life experience to
take that in uh I really do yeah I
really do I mean this
you know I've been very lucky in lots of
bits of my job that I've done over the
years I think that you know it's a great
job it's very hard work a lot harder
than probably what people appreciate and
um but extremely lucky on on loads of
things I do feel within go go chimps in
particular like you say as a human being
from an existential sort of point of
view there's like
so I'm so fortunate and not really not
many people get to see that and they are
our closest relatives and they are
fascinating because of the connections
we have with them they're all so
fascinating because they're different
and they're all individuals and
and it's a chance to just you kind of
feel a part of something the his
you know brought that
important knowledge and information
um to people
yeah so I feel personally very fortunate
yeah